i told you guys uh six weeks ago
seven eight weeks ago that there's this
growing list of things that joe biden
claims he will do
on day one and i told you that we're
going to hold biden to that
i'm going to tell you on day two whether
joe biden did those things and if he
didn't if the day one priorities get
pushed back
to week one or month one or the first
hundred days
that would be a broken promise by joe
biden and i
can't tell you how thrilled
i am to be able to report that joe biden
did it he filed 17 executive orders
yesterday there's a 10 or a dozen more
coming today
which have not yet been signed so i
can't report on those and
doing really really important things
much of this is by necessity covid
related
but much more than that so some of the
executive orders that joe biden filed
yesterday
on coronavirus joe biden law he promised
he would do it and he did it
it's a 100 day masking challenge it's
not a mandate
it's a request that for these next
hundred days as the vaccines start
working their way
through the the population already
starting to see a decrease in
hospitalizations thanks to the vaccines
that everybody wear a mask and indeed a
joe biden did
uh sign a mandate for masks at federal
buildings which is within his purview
joe biden can't mandate masks in state
buildings or in random businesses
or out in in public or in people's homes
and he's not trying to do that but
doing exactly what he promised to do on
mask's hundred day challenge
and mandate in federal buildings
joe biden immediately shut down trump's
withdrawal from the world health
organization
that was a disastrous idea at the worst
possible time
immediately putting dr anthony fauci as
the head of the delegation
to the who in a pre-dawn uh
meeting this morning fauci already
meeting with the who
this is i mean in 24 hours how things
have changed on the economy joe biden
has extended the nationwide moratorium
on evictions and foreclosures until at
least
the end of the first quarter march 31st
and he has extended the pause on student
loan payments and
interest for americans with federal
student loans until at least
september 30th of 2021. he has not
forgiven any student loan debt yet
and that's something many of us want to
see him do but this is a big deal as
well
joe biden has rejoined the paris climate
accord a process that will actually take
close to 30 days immediately reversing
what donald trump did in
bailing on the paris climate accord and
also
joe biden reversing donald trump's
action by
canceling the keystone xl pipeline
period canceled
and directing agencies to review and
reject
and reverse rather 100 trump actions on
the environment i said this must be done
trump's damage to the environment by
loosening regulations has been
disastrous joe biden day one saying
undo all of it joe biden rescinded the
trump administration's 1776 commission
this was that patriotic education
nonsense that donald trump put in place
that's done he also put in a uh
executive order to prevent workplace
discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation or
gender identity
uh there are a number of other sort of
more minor
executive orders but very importantly
joe biden
fortifying daca after trump tried to
gut it reversing the trump
administration's restriction on entry
for passport holders from several
muslim-majority countries that's
the reversal of the so-called muslim
country travel ban
undid trump's expansion of immigration
enforcement within the u.s
and stopped construction on the border
wall
very very important stuff um
there are a number of other executive
orders that joe biden signed yesterday
and more that he will sign today but
this is all
very good and very important and what is
really important to understand here
and we're going to play some clips of a
triggered fox news host
about these orders soon what we
found out is that a relatively small
number of bad actors
trump included who the majority of the
country didn't vote for
remember even in 2016 trump got less
than half of the vote of those who voted
and half the country didn't vote in
2016. a very small number of
bad actors can do a lot of damage and
now
joe biden gets to undo that damage by
the exact same
legal provisions that trump used to do
the damage many of which were executive
orders
but there's a general principle which is
that it's almost always easier to break
and destroy things than it is to build
things consider building a house
you've got to clear the land and then
dig out a foundation and pour the
foundation and then frame it and then
put a roof on and windows and doors
and toilets that trump said you have to
flush 10 or 15 times
and then you bring a wrecking ball in
and in 10 minutes you reduce it to
rubble
that is a a a perfect analogy
um to much of how we saw the trump
administration
operate in very little time trump was
able to destroy global alliances
that took decades to build and to
strengthen
trump was able to by failing on the
virus for a few months
irreversibly set us back okay so i think
we understand the concept
a lot of right wingers are finding
themselves very triggered by joe biden's
executive orders let's talk about that
next
one of our sponsors today is trivia star
a
free trivia game for mobile devices with
over 60 different
trivia categories including things i
know
you would love like geography history
science
many other great topics movies sports
food i've been having a bunch of fun
with it because
i as the player get to choose the
category so i'm only answering questions
on topics i'm interested in
there are over a thousand different
levels to progress to
over ten thousand different questions
which get harder over time so it gets
more and more interesting as you play
if you love trivia like i do i remember
the day's pre-virus of going out to
trivia at a bar
and you want a fun way to keep yourself
sharp check it out
really well designed game 4.9 star
rating and the number one rated mobile
trivia game in the world
and totally free download it
in the apple or android app stores